so there was a video from your NFL
retirement press conference I think it
was like four years ago and you I think
said you had different options but you
weren't sure which path you want to take
and you said you were patient so when I
watch Crown Heights I don't see a
football player acting I don't see an
actor I see the real character I didn't
know who Carl was before the film but I
see someone who I'm lost in that world
so can you talk about being patient and
those four years and and then how it's
all sort of come to where we are now
because this is quite a roll yeah sure I
don't I don't think I'm the fastest
learner but I always say that if I get
something I have a chance to to do it
well that's that was my football career
and switching positions and the thing
that I went through I didn't pick things
up very quickly but I was able to get it
eventually and then succeed at it and so
I've understood patient for a long time
because I just I've known that about
myself so when I finished playing I
didn't at you know I didn't put a time
limit like this has to happen in a year
or this has to happen three years I just
said I'm just going to be patient and
train and learn and see what can come
from it and so I was just blessed to
have an opportunity come a couple of
years later where I could put some of
the training to work
what parallels have you taken from being
in the NFL to now having a career as an
actor and a producer um a lot you know I
tell people all the time I think
football prepared me for life and it's
taught me a lot about life just you know
not even just career-wise but just in
general and I think the leadership
skills that I guess I in football was
something that helped me as a producer
because that's something that you need
it's very very demanding position and
you're in sort of control of every
and everything so I think that helped me
there and I think just as an actor
there's a lot in football as far as just
the preparation that really got me ready
for acting you know just the way that I
knew I had to be a student and I had to
studying and I had to train and then at
the moment where we said go I had to
throw all of that away and just go off
instinct and that's acting you know so I
just used a lot of the same tools that I
did in football has brought it over to
act and you do the same things so
there's so many people that want to be
you know an NFL star and so many people
that want to be an actor how do you feel
that you've been blessed to be both
because that's quite a ride in your
short time on this earth yeah I was just
I was just talking about this with
someone that those are the two things
that when you're in school you know they
say what you want to be when you grew up
in one person said an athlete another
person says an actor and the teachers
like those are the two most difficult
things that you're going to try to do so
I've just you know I'm blessed that I've
been able to you know do both of them
and to have some success at both seekto
- it's not just being blessed it's also
dedication and you know you said about
being a slower learner but I've seen
with slower learners and myself included
that once you get something then you
really grasp it but it takes time yeah
that's definitely how it is for me I
mean there was there's a guy that played
football comes to mind and he he got
like he was always around the ball and
he played defense so he would recover
fumbles he'd get a lot of interceptions
and so people when you were to watch him
you would say oh he's lucky he's lucky
you know he's always lucky I was on the
ball but when I watched him I said no I
think he actually has prepared for these
moments you know and I think it's the
people that prepare for moments that
things actually
start to show up for them you know I was
going out to a lot of directors before
and Crown Heights came I was just
calling directors writing to them and
you know you name the director I
probably reached out to them and didn't
get many returns and probably got like
two from people that you don't know but
you know so it was a little bit
frustrating just trying to
I just wanted to audition for something
or just to let them know that I was
acting and you know at the moment when I
stopped when I got fresh it and I just
stopped us I'm not going to reach out to
anyone directors I'm just going to keep
training it was like a month later that
Crown Heights came from Matt Ruskin so
it's I think it's it's doing the work I
think it's having the faith and the
passion behind it that sort of leads you
to whatever you're supposed to be doing
wondering what Carl King taught you
about life I don't know if you got to
you know I'm much you really researched
beforehand or while you were on that um
what did Carl King takes me well life I
I spent about two weeks with Carl just
trying to get to know him and get to
know what would drive someone to do what
he did and I think I learned more about
him from other people than I did from
him for like his family and his friends
and even talking to call talking to
Colin about him and I think he just sort
of taught me
they both taught me I think about the
power of the human spirit you know and
just being able in Colin's case just
being prison for so long for something
that you didn't do and then coming out
and being able to say I forgive everyone
that put me or had a hand in putting me
in this position was huge for me and
then for call to be on the outside I
mean I don't know you me I don't know
what's going to drive us to work for 21
years
with one singular effort in getting our
friend out of prison like I don't know
who does it you know so it it talking
about the positive hemisphere
he taught me about the power of
friendship and you know Collin taught me
about the power forgiveness you know
these are two guys that I like to say
are the epitome of what it means to be
human
was there a day where before you were
attached to Crown Heights that you said
I'm all in on amis acting whether these
two directors get back to me that they
did or or I faced more rejection but I'm
all-in now yeah I was all-in when I
started you know I don't I can't
half-step I can't I can't just put a
little bit in because then I won't get
the results but then I also don't put
anything into things that I'm not
passionate about or curious about you
know I know from the start if I'm just
in it for other reasons and this was
something that I said from the start I'm
going all-in
you know I'm gonna I'm going to start
training I'm going to figure out how
people are able to transform in the way
that they do on screen and I'm going to
do that you know I just I you know there
was something that I just felt that I
could go after and there was nothing
that was going to stop it so you know
that about yourself from other things in
life including football that it's
there's no halfway with you yeah I mean
there was a time so professionally
speaking as a football player my first
year I came on to the team and like they
switched my position and asked me to
play a position that I've never done
before and in the most difficult place
to do that
and then I fell the most difficult team
to learn that position and thus Kyle and
asked me to do that against guys that
have been doing it for the last ten
years they've been planning this even
for the last eight years so it took me
about a year and a half
for so to really just be all-in and at
first I really fought it and I wanted to
play the position that I was known for
playing and I fought it in the moment
that I went all-in and I was able to you
know sort of turn the tide on on my
career and and I hit the upswing and so
it's just one of the lessons that I
learned and I can just keep that through
the rest of my life at the moment that
I'm all-in on something and I'm really
passionate about it the successor you
know the positive things can come from
it
you